Nothing…happened…
- Scene Breakdown
What is the most iconic moment in all of One
Piece?
Now you yourself might or might not have a
specific answer to this question.
However, whenever people ask me, “Hey Ohara,
what’s your favourite One Piece moment of
all time?”, there are always a bunch of
scenes and events that immediately come to
mind, but ultimately I can never decide which
one I like best.
There is just so much greatness to choose
from, from very emotional stuff, over brilliant
comedy, all the way to some of THE most badass
moments in anime.
So, I thought to myself, if it’s so hard
for you to pick your favourite moment, why
not revisit some of them, find out WHY they
are great, and then pick a favourite.
At first I was thinking about making this
a list video and simply presenting my top
picks, but then I thought to myself that a
video “the top 10 most iconic One Piece
moments” really doesn’t fit in well with
what we’re trying to do here on the channel.
It also sounded like there were probably already
at least a thousand or so of these out there.
And so I quickly scratched that idea and went
back to the drawing board and by drawing board
I mean I got a cup of coffee and watched some
anime, because I’m a goddamn genius when
it comes to procrastinating.
But then I really sat down, and this time,
I fell asleep.
I honestly was a bit discouraged whether I
would be able to pull this off somehow and
was ready to simply ditch the idea and focus
my analysis videos.
After all, that’s what I’m actually good
at.
And then it hit me: Why not do exactly that?
Why not analyse these scenes and see what
makes them tick, why they became so popular
and ultimately pick the most iconic moment
in One Piece.
Apart from a couple of fight analyses, I don’t
think I’ve ever come across a proper scene-analysis
for an anime; and so I welcome you to my new
format: The iconic scene analysis series…I
think, we might have to work on that name
though.
I’m super excited to try something new and
I hope that this format is something YOU will
enjoy as well.
So, let’s give it a go.
To break down every scene, we will be looking
at things like theme, composition, framing,
body language, dialog, symbolism, music and
voice acting in the anime, the role the scene
plays for the overarching story line and much
, much more.
And so, for the very first video in this series,
I thought it might be appropriate to start
with a banger right out of the gate, with
undoubtably one of my favourite moments in
the story and one of the best, if not maybe
THE best in Zoro’s arc: The Nothing happened
scene on Thriller Bark.
The scene takes place shortly after the straw
hat’s united effort to defeat Moria and
his gigantous zombie Oars and stretches from
chapter 483 to chapter 486, and in the anime
it’s episode 377, in case you wanna follow
along.
Luffy is knocked out from his intense final
battle and the rest of the crew, as well as
Lola and her men are resting after they finally
got their shadows back.
However, right when they have defeated one
of the Shijibukai, Kuma suddenly appears on
the island.
He had been tasked to inform Moria of Blackbeard
replacing Crocodile, of Ace having been captured
and of the potential conflict with the Whitebeard
pirates.
However, upon reporting that Moria has been
defeated by Luffy, Kuma reeves new orders
to capture the crew and kill the remaining
witnesses, so no word of Moria’s defeat
can leak into the world to ruin their reputation
even further.
Kuma then compliments the unconscious Luffy
on the crew he has gathered, to which all
of the straw hats react in a hilariously flattered
way, despite the serious situation they’re
in.
And despite the damage all of them took, Zoro
immediately prepares to fight Kuma to protect
his crew, and for the first time in this scene
mentioning his willingness to die fighting,
if necessary.
Kuma however easily repels each of Zoro’s
attacks and introduces his unique devil fruit
powers to the crew, that allows him to repel
anything.
As Kuma catches Zoro by surprise, Sanji jumps
in for the first time to help Zoro.
However, Kuma takes no damage from either
of the two and after proving his superiority,
he offers everyone present a surprising deal,
that goes against his orders.
He will let everyone present on the island
live in exchange for Luffy’s life.
Without so much as a second thought, all of
the straw hats as well as Lola and her men
refuse, and stand between Kuma and Luffy.
As a result, Kuma takes out everyone gathered
there with an enormous shockwave and approaches
Luffy on his own.
However, before he reaches him Zoro, who seems
to be the last one standing, stands in his
way once again.
This time he manages to inflict damage to
the warlord, only to find out that he is indeed
a cyborg developed by doctor Vegapunk and
Kuma reveals the secret government project
of the pacifista.
Having witnessed Kuma’s true strength, Zoro
realises there is no way he can win this fight
in his condition and he bows down to offer
Kuma HIS life instead of Luffy’s, bargaining
his ambition to become the strongest swordsman.
Before Kuma can react however, Sanji , who
seems to be on the brink of loosing consciousness,
steps in, prepared to in turn give HIS life
to save both Zoro’s and Luffy’s dream.
Zoro has made up his mind though, and acknowledging
Sanji’s gesture, he knocks him out with
his sword.
Kuma then proposes another trial for Zoro.
Using the powers of his devil fruit, he expels
Luffy’s pain and fatigue and gives a portion
of it to Zoro, telling him that taking in
all of it would kill him.
Zoro however, takes in all of Luffy’s pain
without a second thought.
Kuma then acknowledges Luffy’s crew and
leaves the island.
After regaining consciousness, Sanji hurries
to Zoro’s side finding him standing straight
in a puddle of blood.
Upon asking what in the world has happened
here, Zoro simply states that - nothing happened
- one of his most iconic lines in the series.
A bit later, Luffy is shown miraculously back
at full strength, while Chopper states that
the now unconscious and treated Zoro only
closely escaped death.
Finally, Sanji stops two of Lola’s men sharing
what has happened, to not diminish Zoro’s
sacrifice.
So, next to the obviously fantastic plot in
here, what makes this scene so damn good?
How did it become one if THE most memorable
moments for Zoro?
The first thing we should look at, is how
the scene fits in with the overall story and
what purpose it serves.
The epilogue scene with Kuma on thriller bark,
to me, seems to have four major implications
for the plot of One Piece.
First of all, it is of course meant to introduce
Kuma as a character into the story.
While at the beginning of the scene Oda implies
him to be a cold and unforgiving government-loyalist,
hammered home by his epithet “the tyrant”,
over the course of events, it becomes clear
that Kuma is in fact sympathetic towards Luffy
and the crew.
Despite his orders and grim threats to take
Luffy’s head, he ends up letting everyone
on Thriller Bark walk away freely.
His affiliation with the revolutionaries is
also already hinted at here, when name-dropping
Dragon.
And so, in just a few chapters, we get an
enormous amount of character development for
Kuma, that is still relevant until now, when
thinking about his role during the reverie-arc.
Secondly, the entire scene contains enormous
foreshadowing, for the next four arcs.
Kuma is the first to mention Ace’s capture
by the marines and the upcoming conflict with
Whitebeard, foreshadowing both the the events
at impel down and marine ford.
At the same time, the introduction of his
powers and his combat superiority towards
the crew heavily foreshadows the events at
Sabaody and finally the time skip, by indicating
that the crew is not strong enough to even
face all of the Shijibukai, let alone the
Marine admirals or the Yonko.
Thirdly, by testing their resolve, the entire
sequence serves as the ultimate proof of the
straw hats’ loyalty towards Luffy, before
heading into the dark trilogy arc of defeat
for the crew.
These three things aren’t as obvious when
reading or watching the scene itself, but
do a wonderful job as an underlying message
and vibe here, that really pays off in the
story going forward.
However, the last and undoubtably most impactful
purpose of this moment, is the characterisation
it gives to Sanji and especially to Zoro,
establishing both of them as Luffy’s left
and right hand and lifting Zoro up, to be
to Luffy, what Rayleigh was to Roger.
More than a crew-member.
More than a friend.
More than a first mate, but a brother, standing
side by side with Luffy, a pillar for his
captain to lean and rely on.
It is some of the best characterisation in
the entire story and, even more than before,
Zoro’s sacrifice made him one of the most
respected and beloved characters of the series.
So, now let’s dive a little bit into the
details here, and I’ll be referencing both
the manga and the anime here, both of witch
have done a fantastic job with this scene
and both of which have their innate bits that
they excel at here.
What I think really stands out in this scene
in particular, even for anime and manga, is
the character’s body language and the fantastic
dialogue.
Kuma’s appearance switches between laid-back
and natural, such as sitting on the wall with
his legs crossed, reading his book and talking
on the den-den mushi - and at other times
moving and behaving mechanical and stiff.
The same goes for his lines, that alternate
between robotic, very simple sentences and
words on the one hand, and quite eloquent
and intelligent lines on the other, that hint
at a smart and compassionate person.
Oda wonderfully uses every aspect of Kuma
to hint at the dichotomy as an intelligent
and friendly member of the revolutionary army
and the brainless, unforgiving machine following
the world government’s orders, switching
between human and machine.
The straw hats meanwhile express nothing but
unity, loyalty and determination through their
body language and their dialog in this scene.
All of them see the danger they are in, and
yet all of them make it clear through their
words and general demena, that they will stand
by Luffy, no matter what.
Especially Zoro and Sanji leave absolutely
no doubt that they see each other as Luffy’s
representation to protect the crew and uphold
his determined and unwavering will in his
stead.
In more than just one scene, Zoro’s face
and the heavy breathing, included in his lines,
hammer home the feeling that he is already
way beyond his last reserves of energy and
is mostly running on willpower and determination
alone.
Nonetheless, the look in his face when stepping
into the bubble of pain, suggests nothing
else than Zoro being fully prepared to die
here, without any regrets.
It is very powerful visual depiction of emotion
and motivation, that the manga does an especially
amazing job with.
And I can’t even begin to describe how powerful
Zoro’s pose at the end is, covered in blood
and at the brink of death.
The anime meanwhile does a wonderful job in
terms of sound design and music in this scene.
The buildup to the climax is accompanied by
uneasy orchestral music, giving the scene
a threatening, cinematic and epic feel, and
once Sanji regains consciousness and hurries
to find Zoro, there is no music at all, implying
something terrible has happened, only to hear
to hear the epic theme of the very strongest
play and seeing Zoro’s defiant face.
Absolute goosebump material.
There is also a nice amount of symbolism in
this scene.
The most striking however, is without any
doubt Kuma removing all of Luffy’s pain
and fatigue and shaping it into an enormous
red bubble, making it visible to us and to
Zoro, what Luffy endues ever arc for his crews
sake.
At the same time, Zoro literally embracing
Luffy’s pain and taking it in, is a wonderful
symbol for the relationship he has with his
captain.
Beautifully executed.
The last thing I wanna look at, is the framing
in this scene.
All throughout the sequence, Kuma constantly
tower over everyone else, representing his
superiority and the helplessness of the crew.
He is literally and obstacle too big to overcome.
This consistency in framing is only broken,
when Zoro offers his life to Kuma in Luffy’s
stead, which shows both of them at the same
level.
Through his words, Zoro has earned to look
eye-to-eye with Kuma and has passed his test
for the crew.
Some other great compositional scene’s include
Sanji standing between Zoro and Kuma and Zoro
bowing down before Kuma to beg for Luffy’s
life, all of which create an even more emotional
and impactful atmosphere than this moment
already carries.
And ultimately, Zoro bleeding with his arms
crossed is shown from below his waist.
After his sacrifice, Oda has given lifted
him to higher moral ground and given him the
perspective, Kuma had throughout the scene.
While each of the elements here, plot, dialog,
composition, etc. is beautiful crafted by
Oda, it is the sum of these elements that
together creates a moment that surpasses its
individual parts.
It’s creates one of the most emotional,
inspirational and suspenseful moments of the
series and it is a prime example of what makes
one piece so great.
If you made it to this point, please let me
know your thoughts are on this new format
and if you would like to keep it going.
Thanks guys.
Peace.